look we've all been there right letting
our fear and anger get the best of us
intentionally expanding the borders of
the false world we created
what's up everybody this week's wanda
vision is out and it is giving us
a lot buckland friends we're going
through a spoilerific recap of a very
revealing episode
i'm carlos bustamante and this is et
canada's nerdler
this week's episode deals with the
aftermath of the major events of last
week
namely vision nearly dying again and
while using her powers to expand the hex
engulfing even more of new jersey in the
process it's probably just a case of the
mondays
am i right oh yeah we've also jumped
ahead in sitcom terms to the modern
family style with an intro
very clearly inspired by the office how
wanda deals with the world shaking
events she's gone through in the last
few episodes is an example of one of the
things one division does
so well here's a woman whose world is
quite literally coming apart around her
and she deals with it by being a sitcom
mom who just needs
a me day now if you look closely you can
see the despair
and suppressed emotions in her eyes it's
really good stuff
i'm fine i'm fine
i'm fine i'm fine
meanwhile we get to see the literal
circus that sword has become
and darcy's big hex transformation into
darcy but with a weird code i mean we
love darcy so why
mess with a good thing but couldn't she
at least have gotten a cool hat
anyway she and vision run away from the
circus which is the exact opposite of a
plan i once hatched when i was eight
years old
vision is questions and darcy has all
the answers how will vision cope with
knowing the truth about his
and rwanda's complicated violent
histories
apparently pretty well so
wanda killed me yes
but it's not that simple i came back and
died again
and she had to watch catching up with
monica and jimmy we get to see who
monica's been planning to meet with
it's not a mysterious aerospace engineer
so we'll still have to wait and see if
any of those theories are true but we do
meet u.s army major goodner whose
loyalty to captain monica rambo hints at
a much larger story to come
likely in captain marvel 2. what happens
next though
gives us a look at what's in store for
monica's future and it is
a doozy
[Music]
as monica pushes her way through the hex
she splits into all versions of herself
and when she emerges on the other side
blue
eyed from the experience she can see the
electromagnetic
spectrum okay so did you see the
interview i did with johnny paris this
week
if you didn't then please take in this
moment we are getting to see
now like pretty like blatant hints that
we're getting to a point where
monica's gonna we're gonna see something
from her
um does the idea of that like people
being able to react to a moment like
that
excite you
[Laughter]
um you know
um i don't know how to answer that i'm
sorry carlos i'm like
there are assumptions in there that i
can't necessarily
[Music]
agree with despite my nerdy ramblings
tiana was very good at holding the line
there and it's
one of the many reasons why marvel
should probably keep her on payroll
forever
because the secret she's been keeping
was a big one this episode
in fact this show is her superhero
origin story
her seeing the electromagnetic spectrum
is a big deal as her powers in the
comics involve her being able to
manipulate
and become pure energy one of her
superhero names
is actually spectrum we get another
small glimpse at her powers later in the
episode when she goes toe-to-toe with
wanda
what's notable here is that the
confrontation does not turn into a
superpowered brawl
instead it's one woman trying to reach
another by sharing her story of grief
offering her sympathy and a connection a
chance to
ah damn it here comes agnes wanda young
lady
i think you overstayed you're welcome in
agnes house away from the prying eyes of
the neighbors wanda can finally relax
with her neighborhood bestie
or can she when wanda asks about her
boys agnes suggests
that they might be playing in the
basement but this is the real moment we
know agnes is evil because you should
never go in the basement good lord wanda
have you never seen a scary movie before
it's there in agnes literal dungeon that
we get the surprise reveal that wasn't
really a surprise because the internet
the name's agatha harkness lovely to
finally
meet you dear
okay now i get that some people watching
might say this would have been a great
shock reveal
if people had not ruined it with their
nerdy internet speculation but
i mean number one agatha's name started
circulating pretty much the exact moment
wanda vision and series were put
together number two i don't think you'd
even be here if you weren't looking to
explore some
potentially spoilery theories right i
mean this is what we're doing we're
having a good time
and number three there's one thing
that comic book fans like more than a
good surprise
that's being right so it's a win-win
i mean the real surprise is that i'll
probably be humming agatha's theme song
while i'm washing dishes later
tonight it's a proper bop
[Music]
so yes agatha has been pulling the
strings behind the weirdness in westview
all along but to what
end what's her plan what does she want
with wanda and her whimsical little
whipper snappers
does it really have anything to do with
the capital m
you know who speaking of who who was the
missing child
on that carton of milk and was this
week's commercial foreshadowing wanda's
superhero return
we don't have a lot of episodes left so
let's get talking about it
in the comments below because we're
gonna find out pretty soon
whether you like it or not also if
you're just along for the ride were you
genuinely surprised
by the reveal of this episode i want to
hear about it i'm carlos busamado you
can follow me on instagram at
low spot if you like this recap please
give us a like and then go ahead and
watch our other nerdy and not so nerdy
videos and remember
if you're in the comments but you're not
participating it's okay
snooper's gonna snoop see you next time
you